first we have a guest the one we
introduced to guests we do have a guest
uh that I'm very happy to have on today
uh he's a journalist uh writer he's the
founder of uh current Revolt uh that
we've uh you've probably seen us retweet
every once in a while and uh the
gentleman that was uh covering Stephen
Crowder's divorce hearing last week uh
Tony Ortiz is joining us here uh live
today how you doing man how you doing
man
oh you're I think you're muted yeah you
have to mute yourself
there you go Boomer moment sorry
honestly no that was actually very
professional of you a lot of people
don't mute you know what I mean they're
like you know brushing her teeth in the
background and doing you're like hey man
we're just gonna do the intro for it in
my nose or something yeah well it's uh
yeah it's good to have you on man we uh
we touched base briefly this weekend and
you kind of came out with very little
notice so I appreciate that
um but yeah so you were
the divorce hearing last week for uh
Crowder and his wife
um so yeah what what I gotta ask what
possessed you to go out there because I
know uh
um I mean I know the story but in case
people haven't read the article yet what
possessed you to go out there in the
first place
yeah you all been covering it a lot
longer than I have or what I've been
aware of you know the only reason we
covered it is it's Texas related so for
those that don't read us and for your
viewers we just cover Texas related news
nothing outside of Texas so if Joe Biden
does something [__] we don't cover
it it's just because it's unrelated to
us Stephen Crowder resides in Texas and
he's a Texas political figure and he
made the choice to make it make his
divorce incredibly public of his own
accord so we decided to attend because
nobody else was covering it um he's been
the only one that's been talking about
it giving his side of things and so we
thought it was worth us um giving some
balance to that
yeah I mean it's it it is you know we
we've been covering when we were
covering him it was after six years it
was absolutely not cool to criticize the
stuff that's now come to light a lot of
it anyway the anger issues the turnover
rate all that kind of stuff and the ndas
I mean it really goes into like you know
kind of the whole thing because you know
we we we're pretty would consider
ourselves a right-wing comedy show but
it's like you know I think we tell
people sometimes like we build up these
walls because people are kind of saying
what you like what you want to hear and
then you kind of people do both sides of
the term blinders like there's there's
something going on you know and for us
it was uh you know everybody around him
was scared to talk the NDA is like
what's going on the anger issues and
stuff like that so you know we of course
kind of felt Vindicated when the initial
story came out like we told you so guys
we told you this is what we were saying
um but how many times have you been
called a leftist oh yeah that's what I
was a couple days yeah it's pretty hard
for the course of our coverage you know
we're we're pretty well known for
covering kind of the TMZ stuff here in
Texas we've covered um I think 12
Affairs now with politicians in Texas
that have cheated on their wives uh
almost exclusively Republican it's just
because you know in in Texas if you
don't like the way Texas is running
you've got to blame a republican
Republicans are in power so we don't
spend too much time criticizing
Democrats just because Democrats aren't
in control here in Texas so yeah the
Stephen Crowder thing you know uh when
we when we express some kind of
criticism for him on Twitter kind of
late into all this you know people call
this leftists or Democrats and things
like that it's just as you know it's
just nonsense um people don't want their
Heroes attacked by any means
yeah it's tribalism it's tribalism and
it's it's it's weird because you know we
if if we criticize somebody on the left
of course we get the we get the pylons
your Nazis you're this you're that
whatever and then as soon as we
criticize and again we're not out to
like attack people it's just when we see
stuff
that somebody does it's very like
disingenuous or we know the real story
it's hard for us to not go hey this
guy's kind of lying and then of course
it's just oh you left this you're
probably antifa you're not even real
concerned it's like all right man I
guess I just wanted to tell you the
truth that I heard that I watched this
thing unfold and you weren't there and
I'm just telling you whatever man you're
just attacking my hero and it's it is
what it is you went there
um so you went there and you were
original this is this is crazy you were
taking notes with your phone right yeah
you know I wanted to be respectful of
the court so and this in retrospect this
was probably stupid um I didn't want to
take my laptop I didn't want to be that
guy clicking around in court you know
typing away
um like an [__] so I just took my
phone um I can type very fast on my
phone as most people probably can you
know
um so I thought I'll take my phone and
I'll just be respectful I'll sit in the
back and just you know watch things
happen and so yeah I walked in with my
phone ready to take notes and you know
before things had even even started you
know you could see both people on each
side of the you know aisle Steven and
his legal team on on their side and
Hillary a couple of members of her
family I assume and um her lawyer on on
the other side and I happened to sit on
Steven's side and everybody was looking
at me like I was like really out of
place and I did I felt out of place but
not my first time in a court hearing
I've attempt attended quite a few um so
you know I knew right off the bat that
you know recordings and video weren't
allowed and in photo so well you know I
just sat there and ready to take notes
yeah and so so it's so that that's so
you look man anybody who's any any
courtroom of any any courtroom is filled
that has somebody of this of his stature
or his level and he's like he's one of
the he'll say what you want about him he
has a lot of followers he is a
mainstream conservative person so I I
find that odd how defensive they they
got that this was being covered like if
I remember correctly we covered it on
the show and I think you brought it up
in the article too he was saying like
you know I want everything to be in
public I want everybody to see what I
wanted I wanted to unseal medical
records yeah he wanted unseal medical
records you know we're gonna basically
and I don't know man I'm not saying it
sounded like a threat you know and it's
it's really odd how the guy who in our
opinion is supposed to be free speech
Warrior we're a free speech Warrior we
want all the informations all of a
sudden like that's the next thing they
asked to seal the courtroom
yeah and that's like what you said
that's my issue with this is that
Crowder has built his platform based off
of free speech he's a free speech you
know hero he constantly pushes for free
speech you know he's gone after and gone
at it with YouTube because they've
censored him right and then so you've
got you've got that issue right and then
and then you compound that with the fact
that Stephen has um I'm gonna refer to
him by his first name not out of
disrespect but just because his last his
wife's last name is Crowders right that
makes sense you know Stephen
um has also uh been very public about
his divorce he's asked for transparency
even revealing medical information which
is really crazy I mean I can I can see
wanting to release maybe transcripts but
to go so far as to release release the
the white the medical records of
presumably of your of your the white the
mother of your children
um that's intense of anybody
um so yeah we thought it was pretty much
we were probably in the right to attend
his court hearings and frankly we went
in there with a relatively open mind
um you know thinking that you know if if
he's right about all this we're are
going to back up his statements
yeah and it's it's it's funny it's funny
kind of watching the the initial recoil
and reaction and something else you
brought up it's like
nobody's nobody was would be telling her
side of the story they just wouldn't
because look this guy has a huge show
he's on our very platform you know and
he and he has a bunch of views you know
hundreds of thousands millions of views
and and what does she have who's going
to listen to her I mean the only other
person that I even saw go to bat for her
was when Candace Owens uh came out and
was saying like look he's like he's a
he's a problem you know
um and and so so then they they asked to
seal to seal the courtroom and and it
says when your article are brought up
because of the protect to protect to
protect his kids like that seems so
silly because well I'll let you tell it
but what was her response to that yeah
so the the argument was to seal the
courtroom to protect the children
um which which doesn't make any sense um
because Steven is already broadcast
everything about this he's attacked his
wife publicly right he's made notes
about her made videos about her so their
first motion immediately was to seal the
courtroom saying that the media has an
unusual interest in the case and it's
like Stephen the reason the media has an
unusual interest in the case is because
you've made the case so public you've
you've been upset on video you've
broadcast things you know then then this
ring video also came out so there's an
excessive amount of drama surrounding
your divorce and you know um if I
remember correctly Hillary's team
responded you know they didn't have a
problem sealing the courtroom they
didn't want to fight that but they did
think that it was unnecessary but they
didn't want to kind of you know fight
that motion if the judge was going to
Grant it
um you know and the judge if you read
the article the judge also eventually
stated that you know it was an odd
request and and kind of out of the
ordinary and said um you know that she
didn't see a reason to seal the
courtroom she said that you know these
things are public
um and also reminded Stephen's team that
you know we have a president of the
United States in this case Donald Trump
uh currently facing a very public trial
first arguably something much more
serious than a divorce and and um you
know that's public right and um you know
that the media had the right to report
on it and that we live in the United
States and we're a free country and so
she denied his motion to seal
yeah no and um that was that was odd uh
that was that was the first odd thing
um the the other thing that I found out
and and this is just based on my it's my
opinion based on what I've seen he
basically lied under oath like he got
caught once when he said uh when they
said did you pick wrong did you say you
picked wrong in a video when you stop
referencing marrying her and he said I
never said that and they literally were
like here's a transcript of the video
you made you literally said it here and
he went all right I guess I said that
and then at the end he swears that he
has never published uh published any
photos of his children online or any of
their information and I immediately went
to his Instagram it's still up I got a
screenshot of it where he literally
posts on Facebook and and uh Instagram
their full names yeah and and pictures
of them and pictures of them yeah so
it's yeah no I was gonna say it's just
this weird ability to just kind of no
just to lie like bold face Gord I'm like
okay it's not true but all right
yeah I wonder if he's arguing semantics
right
um you know if he's saying you know I
didn't publish them in video I published
them in images right like there's
semantics there right there was a point
and I kind of just remembered somewhat
um the other day uh and again a lot of
this if if you're Stephen if you want
the truth of what happened posted you
make it as easy as possible for media to
report on the facts of this issue and
then you have my you have my phone taken
away and I don't have pen and paper so I
have to go run and borrow pen and paper
and then I didn't put this in the
article my damn pen ran out of ink
halfway through so I'm sitting there
like inscribing into paper these notes
you know but um you even said that in
the article you go at this point I had
to scramble for a pen and paper this is
all now going to sound really disjointed
and insane because you were just trying
to write yeah and it kind of
court reporter the guy that's
responsible for typing everything up he
he I think they interrupted the court
three or four times to yell at the
attorneys because they kept just talking
over each other and he couldn't
effectively report so if you've got a
guy who's literal job profession is to
take notes and he can't effectively
deliver proper notes it's going to make
it a little harder for somebody like us
so you know there there was a time where
um Hillary's lawyer bought up a point
about
um he said something along to the line
along the lines of has a former employee
ever complained that you have rubbed
your genitals on them and Stephen
replied no that's that's never happened
and uh if I remember correctly Hillary's
lawyer said you know are you sure like
you're under oath you're saying that
nobody's ever complained about this and
he's like no nobody's ever complained
about this and then Hillary's lawyer
said something like there was a New York
Times or newer post or something article
published where an employee complained
that you rubbed your genitals on them
and he said something along the lines of
oh yeah that was the New York Times and
it's like I think he was playing
semantics with like yeah an employee
didn't complain that you are times
complained you know so I don't know if
that's the case I don't want to put
words in his mouth right but that's just
kind of my opinion is maybe he's playing
semantics and not not lying under oath
but maybe playing with the words
back to the phone thing you said in the
article you pointed out that the one of
his lawyers walked behind you to see
what you were doing and then accused you
of recording is is that what happened
yeah yeah so you know uh like I said I
this isn't my first court hearing I've
been to plenty ones of my own and ones
of others so this is not this is not my
first rodeo so I I know that recording
is illegal I know that audio video is
illegal photos legal I mean that's why
you have court artists right they draw
pictures you don't have them taking
photos because in some cases these
courts are sealed um from from video and
audio so knowing that you know I'm
taking notes on my phone and I see one
of his lawyers get up and walk behind me
and you know I don't want them to see my
notes I don't want anybody to see my
notes it's private it's not that there's
anything bad in there but it's got
they're very rough it's got my
highlights in there maybe my opinions
that I'm not going to publish but things
that I want to bring up you know and so
I I swipe my phone to the left and I
post that screenshot of my phone in the
on on the on the article and um I still
see him standing over me and it's
displaying my battery life in in green
lot in green lines right and he leaves
okay and then maybe like two minutes
later a court employee or government
employee staff or whatever comes up
behind me it's a nice woman and she's
very polite about it she's like Hey sir
I just want to let you know you can't
record and I said yeah I know I show her
my notes I'm like here's here's my phone
right and she goes okay thanks and then
she leaves and you know the the judge
and Steven's team and Hillary's lawyer
are still going at it right they're
talking and I'm I'm going back to taking
notes and all of a sudden the the judge
stops interrupts everybody and goes you
over there with the blue shirt come up
here and gotta admit that's a little
freaky right like of course you're in
the middle of a doorstep seating and
this judge is like screaming at you to
approach the bench so I go up there and
she asks me my name and I identify
myself and she asks if I'm there as on
behalf as a citizen or on behalf of the
media and I said I'm with the media and
she asked me to identify my media outlet
and she says um are you aware that
you're not allowed to record
um proceedings and I said yeah of course
I'm aware of this and uh Steven's lawyer
gets up puts his hand on his heart
raises up his hand and says your honor
as a steward of the court or something
that affects as a steward of the court I
solemnly swear that um that gentleman is
recording I saw green lines that have
that
um Show Audio is recording on his phone
and I said your honor I'd be glad to
show you my phone right now but you know
I'm not recording and she goes bailiff
sees his phone so they attach my phone
and this is without me I didn't have a
chance to lock my phone right I don't
have anything to hide so I kind of don't
I kind of don't care but at the same
time it's like it's weird it's a little
it's a little weird it's an invasion of
space it's an invasion of privacy to
read text from my wife or whatever you
know my my swole picks right or whatever
you know
and so um you know he grabs my phone and
he's he's going through it like I'm
seeing him scrolling and I see him
hopping hopping screens and things like
that you know and um and then you know
luckily you know eventually after maybe
like a few minutes or I don't know how
long he takes my phone he puts a face
down and he locks it so uh I'm without a
phone and then maybe 10 minutes later
they go on recess I approach the bailiff
and I said hey can I get my phone back
and he goes yeah that's not happening
the judge wants to talk to you first and
I said okay I said well in the in the
incident that I have to or the emergency
I have to leave can I grab my phone at
that point and he goes I'm not sure uh
I'll have to I'll have to I can see if
you want if you need to leave and I said
no that's fine and I said by the way I'm
not recording and I said I just want to
let you know this is my first time I'm
not he goes yeah I know you're not
recording it's okay cool I go grab and
pen and paper and then I go back to uh
to writing by hand
that's so annoying and such a way and it
was such a
such a little petty move like it feels
Petty it definitely feels Petty like
screw your day up kind of thing and I
don't know just yeah yeah I mean he's
very it's very clear with the with the
hiding of the court date right so for us
also it is incredibly hard to find this
court date it's not it wasn't on the
docket um it was incredibly hard to to
find out when this was happening so he
or his team or even maybe maybe even
Hillary's team went to effort to hide
this court hearing date and time okay so
not only that you compound that with the
fact that they immediately motion to
seal the courtroom they they referenced
multiple times they're concerned about
me and the media being in the room and
then your lawyer is effectively and I
don't know if again I don't want to put
words in his mouth and I don't know his
real intentions but he effectively lied
about the what I had on my phone and
getting my phone taken away I mean
you've got you basically got this guy
Stephen that that genuinely does not
want his his stuff reported despite the
fact that he's going on Twitter making
videos and talking public about all this
yeah I I think he doesn't want people
reporting independently on it he wants
people to report on his statement and
just go with that and move on which is
why I do respect you going through the
effort to go through this and
um because again as you pointed out in
the article uh the other side of this
story is not getting anything you know
and nobody's been nobody's been telling
the other side of the story except maybe
us for a couple years but nobody we're
not you we're not journalists nobody's
going to take us seriously we're not
going to go to a trial and sit there and
say you know it's like it's not
happening so we only have what we have
um I did have to ask one more thing
because this was in your article um
they brought up the children you know
safety thing and she said that there's
been no threats to the children
uh but that's something somebody mail
the potatoes
somebody mailed them a potato
right yeah and um you know I didn't I
gotta admit I I probably would have
laughed have I seen that video that you
played yeah because now now I get the
potatoes yeah um but at the time it was
just absurd I was like what a potato I
almost wanted to ask for a repeat like
what are you talking about yeah the the
Hillary's lawyer basically said
um you know there's been no threats of
violence uh this is all generated by
Stephen and the only thing that we've
had that's out of the ordinary is a
potato was mailed to the house
threatening like I was I was supposed to
understand that that's threatening is it
edible can I eat the potato that sounds
like maybe a gift like maybe it's a
gourmet potato maybe I could maybe I can
explain it to you see sometimes Steven
wants a potato and yeah
one of my colleagues was like was this a
joke about him sticking the potato
somewhere like I don't know well that's
that's always our first well we have
this video that that we that we've
Acquired and the only thing I'll say is
that so nobody put it to you this way
everything in that video that we played
is not it's not a joke everything in
that video is things that he does
actually require staff or former staff
to do so that's why the video is so
funny because we first played the video
people were like that's crazy who does
it I'm like these are like from emails
that he wants that somebody put together
in video form so I believe that that's
what the potato thing is about oh that's
that's really really important you know
I went into this not knowing a lot of
this right because I don't I don't you
know uh like I said I my brain is so
enveloped in Texas politics when it
comes to National stuff and like Stephen
Stephen Crowder and e-celebs I really
don't care like Steven could go on an
hour try out about Biden and just I
don't give a [__] right yeah it just
does anyone else I don't watch his
content too much I'll watch it when he's
local like he covers a lot of uh local
colleges here
um so I'll watch some of those sometimes
if it's relevant or interesting but for
the most part I don't watch a show I
don't interact with it I don't subscribe
I don't
um I'm not a mug Club member or anything
like that I I know some of his former
employers current employees right
um and so yeah with this this stuff
about his employment and like the way he
manages his team
um I gotta admit it's kind of not
surprising you see a lot of these celebs
that are kind of like Madonna's right
like Rihanna's they just have like these
crazy
um view of self-worth they think that
they're way bigger than they actually
are and you know it didn't surprise me
when I saw these things I I haven't been
able to confirm them or deny them I
haven't looked into them myself nobody's
emailed me documents or anything
confirming these this funny video but um
it is it is well the problem with that
funny video and here's here's the issue
that you fall into when if you if you do
go down this Rabbit Hole as we've done
the issue is is that Steven has uh
Stephen makes all of his employees sign
uh ndas
non-disclosure agreements so even if
people want to say something obviously
they can't say anything without getting
into some sort of of legal trouble he's
somebody who is granted in my opinion I
mean from what you hear is his dad
pretty much runs runs runs the show over
there but he's very very good at
shielding himself from any from any sort
of a public backlash and I think what
Stephen the hardest was he's always
portrayed himself as like you know I'm
the dad and the wife stays home and
which just moves on to the next thing I
was going to ask they asked her when are
you looking to get a job yeah that was
weird man that was very weird to me
because it's supposed to be like I'm
going to take care of you this and that
because that's that's the Persona that
he puts out there you know the whole
like you know father mother and then I
was like oh I chose wrong and my wife's
dumb and it's all control one car uh
well I don't want you working I want you
at home and then when we get divorced
well why don't you get a job
right right it's all mentals forms of
control ndas everything like that so
yeah I I mean did you get that
impression
yeah though you know I saw that video by
I was yashar ali um yeah the one car
thing is weird they didn't address that
in court uh that weirds me out I think
even the average middle class family has
two cars especially especially if you
have you're about to have kids yeah yeah
uh and you know especially if like
you're taking the car out you're at work
like you want your wife to be able to
leave in an emergency you know something
happens and she's got to go it just
seems odd but I don't know maybe his car
was in the garage or as a shop you know
maybe it's broken I don't know what the
case is he never addressed it he's never
addressed it publicly despite being very
public about everything else he's never
addressed the car issue but I mean if
I'm Steven and I make millions of
dollars a month I'm I probably have like
four or five cars because it seems a
little odd that he only has one it's a
control even for himself like I would
have a convertible like an SUV a truck
like it just seems weird that he would
only have one for himself so or not even
or not letting her Uber or give because
even she even offered in that video like
oh my friend will give me a ride and he
was like No And I just it's it's very
it's very and obviously the Optics don't
look that good when you're sitting
sitting in a cigar a lot of sitting
smoking it's a guy
his demands for Uber people were
theorizing that it was so that he could
see where she's going he could track her
on a map you can see the destination he
knows how long she's gone right and
whereas if she has arrived from a friend
they could be taking them anywhere so
right you know who knows again just the
theory but yeah that was weird you know
um I I he came across just as like you
know not not super likable you know so I
hope in his case I hope his lawyers
trained him to be a little more likable
um you didn't come across too happy or
uh you know and and I think it was just
mostly salty in his team the fact that
media was there covering it oh yeah
because I mean will we find and same
thing with us like we we get a lot of
[__] because we we cover right-wing
people too when they're being stupid and
doing dumb [__] so you know and and it's
like no no no no no you have to be able
to listen if you're going to be freedom
of speech guy if you're going to be
everything's out in the public if you're
going to be changing my mind if you're
going to be that guy then look when it's
your turn you have to be out there and
and and be open about it the truth of
the matter is he's not so much mad that
he in my opinion again that he lost his
wife or anything he's mad that he's
publicly being embarrassed Stephen
doesn't want to be publicly embarrassed
because in his head it's always been our
opinion he thinks he's the next Andrew B
Breitbart he thinks that he really
thinks that's that's his calling in life
that that's the guy but in reality it's
somebody who look granted hit it big
making a lot of money he has a humongous
contract all these things are great but
he still does kind of act like this
petulant child who just doesn't get what
he wants he gets angry now going back I
forget when did the judge give you your
phone back was it yeah so after yeah it
was after everything had settled right
um the court proceedings were done uh I
just kind of sat there kind of twiddling
my thumbs hoping that somebody would
notice that they still have my damn
phone so luckily the the sheriff noticed
and he went up to the judge and was like
hey you got to deal with this guy
basically and she she called me up to
point it at me told me to come up and
she said um she basically did that thing
where like they assumed that you're
recording so she's like okay now show me
the recording and I'm like your honor
like it's impossible for me to do that
for you because there is no recording
and she goes uh I want to let you know
that if a recording or photo or audio or
video appears online of this of this
court case
um I'm going to hold you in contempt
report and have you arrested and jailed
and I said yeah I'm not worried about
that though your honor like I haven't
done any of this it's not my first Court
proceeding I said be more than happy to
show you my phone and opened my phone
and I showed her my notes and I said
here's like 12 screens of notes that
I've taken up to a point when you took
my phone and she said okay that's fine
uh you're free to go and I left that was
it it was um it was odd I've never had
that happen I I actually frankly
wondered the legality of being able to
seize my phone without my permission I
don't know how to go through that
without my permission I don't know
either I would actually like to know
that too because that seems I mean I
don't know if you like forfeit any
rights if you're in a courtroom I don't
know how that works but it does seem
weird that they could just take your
phone for and it just however long they
want
um and and yeah I assume they can write
up a warrant I mean she's right there so
if I was just like hey I demand a
warrant for this she could just be like
here you go go through his phone so yeah
I don't like that though because then it
then it's like okay now you're in my
phone and now that gives you this what
does that now give you uh like the
permission to just go through everything
it also sets me up for potential
problems like or whatever I don't know
if the sheriff put anything on my phone
what if he uploaded photos like photos
that are gonna get me in trouble what if
he took the things from my device what
if I have confidential information on my
phone now he has access to it it opens
up me to potential liability
um so I don't know what he did you know
for the time he had my phone he sat
behind a computer desk going through my
phone I don't know if he hooked it up to
a computer and clone to my device so I I
don't know I don't know but it was
definitely uh it definitely made me very
annoyed that um that uh Steven's lawyer
lied about that it'd be different if it
was the truth then it's like okay you
got me but that was a flat outline so
yeah it's um again it's to [__] with you
it's a control thing it's you know just
like going on we're saying about how you
know Crowders not happy about this right
now and it's it's not just like what you
said because he's you know a baby but
it's also this is the first time that I
can remember where he's in a situation
he's in no control of like he's always
in control and now it's like you're not
in control it's an open public forum
that it's going to be tried in court and
you're going to have media there and
even to say like because I'm sure
there's been some people that have
accused Tony you know all this is you're
probably just you know trying to create
narrative or you just want some
salacious headline I read the whole
article multiple times it's literally
notes there's no speculation there's
there's no like you do you don't opine
in it at all it's literally okay you
guys want me to go I'm here I'm gonna
write down notes uh Hillary says this
lawyer said this Stephen then says this
she says this it's literally yeah I mean
we're we don't pretend to be non-biased
we're a right-wing news rag right so I'm
a I'm a right-wing guy I have right-wing
opinions and I look through things in a
right right-wing you know view so I'm
not pretending to be this non-biased
neutral you know journalist um I'm not
and I I'll never say that I am you know
but um you know it's just the the fact
that he was censoring this so much and
you know it would have been really easy
for him uh and I'm surprised his lawyers
didn't even tell him to do this just you
know just say something from the very
get-go from the minute he's going at it
with Candace Owens like hey guys you
know I'm going through divorce as you
know there's two sides to every story I
I don't want to get into this she's the
wife I'm my kids I just would appreciate
some privacy and some respect while I go
through this and that's all I'm going to
say on the matter going forward and then
just be done right and then you wouldn't
have any of this you wouldn't have
people showing up to courts you wouldn't
have you know streams going on about his
divorce case because there wouldn't be
any drama and he wouldn't have so much
attention but he made what two two
recordings about this and it's just um
it's a Streisand effect in full um in
full effect well because he thought he
was bulletproof for so long that that's
what it goes into when you when you
think it's it's like in our it's like
the end of Scarface when Tony Montana's
on so much coke that he thinks he could
take everybody down you know this guy
has been bolstered not only by by his
parents by everybody he's he's always
been in control it's always been him
versus the little guy I think what hit
him the hardest is when right-wing news
out was when right wing shows started
being like hey man this is the mother of
your children that really bothered him
because he kept saying like you know I'm
and she said that he punched holes
through the walls which by the way I
think we all knew he did that I don't
think we need it's nice to have somebody
say it but I think definitely can see
he's a guy who probably punches a molts
and drywall he's always been a guy that
struck me as very wound up yeah he's
just very wound up yeah there was there
was no evidence given that he punched
um his team didn't object to it so they
didn't deny it
I don't know if they would have anyway
but they didn't object to it you know
um so you know she said they had rage
issues and they I know that there was an
objection for the word rage and his
lawyer said something along lines of
like you cannot Define the word rage and
then that was overturned yeah um so the
judge was like yeah you can Define rage
something something to that effect
um so that went on you know
um I don't know again I don't know
Steven personally I don't know his
employees I don't know his staff or I
should say I know one of his employees
but we don't talk
um but you know I don't I don't know
what the the situation is over at
Crowder headquarters
um I went there to get some information
get a story you know report back again
I'm not trying to be biased I have a
right wing lean on everything I report
um so yeah I view this from a
conservative Viewpoint to me my opinion
you know if these allegations are true I
don't think it's very conservative to
punch a hole in the wall with your wife
there you know the mother of your kids
it's just not you know you know and you
know in Stevens defense you know we've
all been in relationships where women
wound us up oh listen here let me let me
tell you I updated I've dated some
habitual buttons bro bro
I'm Cuban I know 100 how much like a
wine trust me I know so I get it look we
all get angry in this but I think it's
not so much getting wound up and getting
angry because look look women could be
[__] insufferable we know that but
the the the the other thing is like but
we're also not the ones portraying
ourselves as these beacons of the
conservative family and look how great I
am and look I do things right you know
the father should work and the mother
should stay home and it's it's to us
it's always reek like you know those
evangelicals that talk about like you
know all the bible stuff then they get
caught having like you know gay sex in a
bus terminal you're like okay you know I
don't care what you do in your private
life but now you're the one that's
portraying yourself being a certain way
and the other thing that I found you
were going off about gay people for
years right and then we call you in a
bus station right like so you you were
having gays jails and I also find that
if this if this if the what was
happening to to Crowder when I was
happening to Hunter Biden for example
Crowder will be covering it'll be
reading all this stuff Crowder would be
saying all this stuff Crowder will be
saying that some other of your children
making bad songs about it making
terrible parodies they're so bad parody
songs about it and stuff like that but
but the other thing that I thought was
wild was she again this is her side we
don't know what's true or not but he
wasn't there when his kids were born
which again what I thought was really
weird
you know it felt it felt like why why
weren't you there you know I and look
the other thing the one of the things
that I want to bring up here is with in
relation to what he said was he went out
of his way to bring up that he had a
medical procedure that was so serious
that insurance even covered it now the
reason that's anyone who hears that
outside goes why would you bring that up
who cares was because when Candice Owens
was talking about it she said it was a
cosmetic procedure that he didn't need
it because he had that you know
something about that sunken bird chest
here in the middle and look he works out
a lot he's very vain you could see he he
was he want he was saying that was a
cosmetic procedure and he wants to make
sure and his thing was like it couldn't
have been a cosmetic procedure insurance
covered it I'm like all right come on
man yeah it's not he made it sound like
his chest was slowly collapsing like a
[__] roof with too much snow on it
and it's like that's not what it is it's
just you know say what it is the other
thing I found interesting and you wrote
this in the article is that he also
weaved in this little thing about covid
yeah and he was like well covid was
limiting the number of people that could
be allowed in the hospital or whatever
and I'm thinking so Stephen Crowder the
guy who has made his entire fortune on
manufacturing culture warrior [__] you
have to have a crusade if you you know
what I mean to make money of course of
course so you're telling me that the
reason you weren't at the birth of your
children was because they wouldn't let
the father of these kids in the hospital
room during the birth
because of covet and you failed to bring
that up you didn't make that a huge
Crusade like that he could have made
Millions from you know you're not going
to keep me from my kids you know and he
could have went on this hole that that's
that's his business model how did he not
yes I don't believe it just that I mean
even if he didn't want to uh and again
this is my opinion right of course we
won't know until I mean if you I don't
know he's still intent on releasing
medical records but
um if even if he was intent on following
covet rules I would assume if there was
a if there was a limitation on who could
be in the room the father would say hey
Dad can you can you bail out for a
second we can swap out while I see the
birth of my kids or hey mom and dad and
sister can you can you swap me out and
put me in so I can be there when you
know cut the umbilical cord or whatever
I assume again he and then he also
claims that there's video of him there
so I don't know it was really it was
really odd when we haven't seen that
right like there was no
um I think some evidence was submitted
and I did see a photo submitted of him
holding his baby oh yeah the the one the
one the one that he posted that he said
he's never posted a picture of his kids
yes yeah the one from Instagram where
he's in a hotel room yeah I think
I think shirtless and he was holding
they said like he I know that his his
legal team did submit that but um you
know the the court proceeds were only
two and a half hours long you know they
claimed there's more evidence of her in
erratic Behavior what was submitted as
far as erratic Behavior How It's the
funniest part it was yeah I did I did
think it was a little odd I mean I
assume you know I assume that if you're
going to cite erratic Behavior you lead
with I assume you would lead with I'm
not a lawyer but I assume you lead with
at least some strong stuff and he led
with the fact that um I guess there was
a Twitter post up that had his address
on it and that it was up for several
months and she didn't inform him that
that his address was posted online which
seems odd to me you know Steven's team
not only Steven but Steven's employees
also have a pretty big uh presence on
Twitter I mean I have I have his staff
in my replies
um defending him pretty consistently
um Tara price and um Casey Hill are in
my reply is pretty upset about our cover
our coverage which is fine they're ever
they're in their right too you know I
you got to make a living the economy
[__] so you take your jobs
Amen brother Amen Brother on your side I
don't
I don't hold Steven's employees or staff
to any kind of ill will I mean they're
just doing their job I would I would I
hope my team would defend me if
something happens right but
um you know so you know he decided that
there was this this tweet online and
with their address and that he was mad
that it took his wife two months to
inform him or several months to inform
him which seems odd because if you're
not if you don't have a Twitter account
how are you supposed to see
tweets about you you know like I don't
know it just it just seems weird to me I
don't have a I don't have a I don't
think I have a Pinterest account so I
have something gets posted on Pinterest
I'm not going to know unless somebody
shows it to me so that was odd and then
um there was another thing about what
was it basically that uh you know she
she submitted the uh yeah the ring video
right yeah
um you know he he says that she
submitted it and then he it then later
admits that it wasn't it was his wife or
his wife's family that submitted it to
this um this journalist right and you
know in again semantics in play right I
mean I I we can assume we can assume
that the way his wife's family got a
hold of it is his wife gave it to his
family and then his family gave it to
her family and then her family gave it
to the reporter so it's kind of like
he's technically right right right
um so I don't know but I mean you know
are you mad that a ring you're you're
talking about releasing medical records
and you're mad that a ring video was
posted it seems kind of weird to me yeah
but I also understood here that the
judge says that neither side now is
supposed to talk publicly about the case
so they've even was going to receive
really least medical records that might
hinder him from doing that because the
judge that's true yeah yeah in his
defense you know and I I admittingly in
his defense yeah he can't defend himself
now his lawyer made that point right
like we we want the ability to be able
to talk about this case because Steven
has his reputation to defend right um if
he's got to be able to talk about his
side of things and um you know that but
she put in a gag order so you know I'd
love to you know you can um with court
transcripts to my knowledge uh chord
transcripts you could order them
um it's fifteen hundred dollars is what
my lawyer estimated wow are these poor
transcripts
um I'm trying to get up the fund I don't
have Mud Club money so I'm trying to get
up the funds because I would love to
release them to the public uh for you
want to chip in on that hey yeah hold on
we'll throw something everyone happily
throw some in on that we'll have these
yeah we'll go halves these let's get it
done we'll do it all right all right so
yeah like I'm all about transparency
right and so I see a lot of Steven
Crowder's fans um you know wanting the
transcripts and I agree with them right
I mean you know his team took away my
phone I what you know up to a point the
the notes that I was able to take which
is best that I was able to write down
with them talking at a million miles per
hour
um so there's probably a good amount of
stuff that maybe I missed right the the
genitals on a face or what genitals on a
person is something that I missed to
report right so I should have probably
wrote that up but yeah you know we want
to order this transcript would love to
publish it publicly
um you know if you guys are going in
I'll give it to y'all and you can run
with it right I really don't care
um I'm all about just getting
information out and letting the public
decide
um so I wanted to also ask like did and
you're just I'm just asking your opinion
here does it seem at least odd in your
opinion too that he's just going for
like full-blown full-on custody when
right now they have shared custody it
feels Petty to me for somebody to be
like I want full custody that's it and
then and then to say she's got like
erratic Behavior to me like I want full
custody This Woman's erratic should be
like she's on drugs she's living out of
motels or you know one night I woke up
and she'd put uh the baby in the [__]
oven and the [__] you know the turkey
in the crib or something I remember that
a listing story yeah what I mean then
you go okay you're on I want an
emergency Junction right now but it just
seems like he's like yeah she doesn't
have a Twitter didn't tell me her
address was on Twitter and you're like
what that's yeah you know when when the
case started and they mentioned that he
was going for full custody I was like
wow um that's a pretty intense extreme
ask so I'm ready to hear that like
Hillary does drugs and like yeah
not him with like 20 other men and like
all this other stuff right she's coming
home at like four in the morning drunk
like I'm ready to hear these things and
you know the first thing up is Twitter
complaints and then the second thing is
this ring video and I'm just like
where's the beef right where's the
where's the real stuff where's the the
crazy stuff and presumably he's not done
right I mean we've got more court cases
we only had two and a half hours
um so I assume that he's I I assume he's
got a lot more evidence to propose and
maybe he's saving the best for last so
maybe we're gonna hear some crazy stuff
uh at the next court hearing but from
what he presented
um the judge did not I mean the judge
says you know I'm not um I'm not leaning
towards changing any custody she didn't
give a ruling but at the time she said
I'm not convinced so yeah because they
currently have like a shared deal so
it's kind of ready for anybody any one
side to come in and go I want full
custody he's usually a pretty I mean I
think yeah what's the best I'm not like
you said unless she's doing something
horrendous you probably want both kids
to have both parents the kids have both
parents in their lives right yeah yeah
and then you know some people sent me
some DMS showing that Crowder has
admitted that in the past where he
supports Mom and Dad raising the kids in
a way I haven't seen I mean I don't know
the veracity I don't know if those are
real or not but I've been said DMS of
him saying and talking about how like
you know kids need their mom and their
dad right and so ideally if he believes
that you would want your kids to also
have a mom
um and I also assume that just Crowder
is insanely busy I mean I I'm insanely
busy I couldn't imagine raising twins by
myself I would if I was in crowded
situation my parents would essentially
be raising my my kids um just because I
don't have time to deal with it I'm
running a Empire a media Empire and you
know staff I don't have time to deal
with two twins and so you know in my
opinion I would think you know you let
let the kids stay with Mom and you get
them on the weekends and you be that
cool weekend dad and maybe get them for
the summer and I said that I said that
on nightwave I was like yeah I was like
I want to be weekends and Summers Dad
I'll be the [__] status yeah you buy
the ice cream take them to the mall
there's no school they just associate
you with no school yeah yeah yeah you
know I'm a product of divorce my dad was
the weekend dad and he was he was cool
as hell and you know we talk every day
and you know he was the summer dad and
we went out and we he took me out
playing Pokemon cards and tournaments
and [__] that was that he was the cool
dad right my mom was like I [__] hate
you you're making me do my homework and
dad wants to take me to play Pokemon
cards you know she's yelling at you to
get your coat you're gonna miss the bus
and so you know with the way their setup
is you know he gets the kids three days
a week plus some Saturdays and she gets
them the rest of the time and
um to me that to me that seems fair
especially with how busy it is that
she's a full-time mom's like what she
got going on anyway you might as well
let her take care of the kids I don't
know I mean I I mean look it's probably
in my guess that sounds like a she
probably knows he's not going to get it
but probably a setup to not pay as much
would be my guess you know which also
would would make sense considering that
his his lawyer was pretty in insistent
about asking about her employment
um like hey when are you getting a job
do you have a job when's the last time
you had a job I mean there was quite a
few questions uh concerning her
employment you know uh so I can only
assume that's partially to get the legal
or not the legal fees but the alimony a
little lower than it needs to be it's
like your honor this woman has no
intention of working she's going to live
off my wealth so he's worth he's worth
millions she's got two they got twins if
she's got partial custody whatever she's
gonna have to get something from the
divorce anyway I know Texas for sure
yeah I think it's a 50 50 state and then
it's like 25 for the kids if there's two
kids of like ongoing money but yeah I
can see why he's if that's the case you
know I mean I don't really know too much
about Texas divorce too much but if
that's the case then I can see why he's
so insistent on I'm fighting this as
much as possible I mean 100 you're worth
plus twenty percent if you're worth this
kind of money how much of an effect is
her going to get a job as a receptionist
at a [__] dentist officer is she
going to work at a Pinkberry and they're
going to go wow you just saved Millions
here Steve yeah it's still you still do
you [__] up yeah and now you're in a
situation yeah well he's got four
lawyers four lawyers yeah I mean four
lawyers are not cheap and I guarantee he
doesn't have cheap lawyers really good
lawyers maybe he should have just
[__] put the medicine on his own
[__] dog yeah put the gloves on and
put the medicine on your dog Jack cat
donated 20 says this twenty dollars for
the crowded transcript you boys are
doing the Lord's work Wang Wang Wang
Niles Niles Van Wilder is Burke Chrysler
Wang Wang thank you sir yeah people
people want to know about this we I want
when's the next date yeah do you know
when the next don't don't have that yet
you know I've had I've had a lot of
reporters reach out to me to ask to
attend this so I I'm more than happy to
share dates with whenever we get them
with what other media wants to be there
um like I said I'm not trying to make
this an exclusive it's not like our
article is not a paywalled article I had
I had people accusing me of trying to
profit off of this we don't run ads you
know we make money off subscriptions
we've got a little donate at the button
at the top of our page but you know
we're not uh we're not trying to profit
off of his Misfortune we're just trying
to cover news and you know in a
roundabout way yeah it gets his media
attention and hopefully some subscribers
but you know particularly I I have no
ill will towards Crowder I don't know
him on a personal level I just know his
off and I have liked his content I
really don't know him from a personal
level
um hopefully I maybe he'll show more
towards his side at the next court
hearing but nothing against the guy I
just want to be able to show another
side of the story which I think we've
done pretty well yeah you know it's but
you know the whole like you're not
trying to even if people were trying I'm
not not saying that you are but even if
people were trying to profit office
Misfortune that's his business model too
like it's hard to when you do something
like that right to then get mad at
people for like he's profit let's go out
for the stories that he's profited on
there Misfortune you know happens all
the time you know whenever something bad
happens a hunter bite and he's talking
about it and look we all do we all
listen man we all in a little way profit
offer that's the way it works like you
said the economy [__] you know but you
know it's you're now getting mad that
people are doing to you what you built
your Empire right off of which is
criticizing people getting in their face
changing their mind you know making
money off of people's misfortunes you
know but making fun of making in front
of of Bernie Sanders like it's that's
that's that's the game and the problem
is once you're in the game you're in the
game you know what I mean and and that's
he's always wanted our opinion we always
are Crowders always wanted to be the
dude he's wanted to be the the rock star
the the the the Crowders in the building
you know the rock the rock stars here
check it out here he is well this is the
downside that comes another look what
Johnny Depp went through you know a
little Crowder's obviously a tiny
percentage of what Johnny Depp is but
that's what you get when when you're at
the top people are going to microanalyze
your life especially if you're agitating
people which you do if I was getting
like a divorce right now I'd be thinking
[__] here we go yeah like people are
going you know what I mean like not on a
level of him but this you like ah
there's gonna be a [__] you know
there's gonna be a hundred or so people
that are like I need every detail about
this [__] because you're like oh here we
go and there's gonna be people reading
the transcripts because you know and and
you know maybe I would even be one of
those people that's like hey you know
leave this alone if he if you
specifically ask for privacy but but he
didn't he asked for medical records to
be released he had for Trans or Court
motions to be released he made multiple
videos right and so if he was if he was
on one side saying hey this involves my
kids and like I want privacy and I don't
want to bring attention and stress out
my my ex-wife or the mother of my kids
and you know I want to focus on doing
good conservative stuff and and take
care of my staff and you know deal with
this divorce and I just appreciate some
privacy at this time then I would I
would be there right with everybody else
being like hey just leave this guy alone
like you know you guys just let him let
him deal with this and move on with your
life but he did the exact opposite he's
done everything opposite to that and so
it does seem hypocritical that now he's
very anti-free speech very anti-media
very anti-coverage and wanting
everything sealed and stuff it's just he
totally flipped and you got to ask
yourself what's the motivation for that
why would you why would you flip all of
a sudden is it because you control the
narrative and now you don't and now you
want to shut it down or because
something's actually wrong or what
what's the issue there it does seem odd
yeah it's it really should have had a
good Zinger to come back at when they go
you can't record in the courtroom you go
I know it's a courtroom it's not a phone
call with Jeremy boring hey do the
double guns out that's the other thing
that's a good point he all of this like
be careful but he recorded a phone call
a contract negotiation with Jeremy
boring and now you're like oh please
don't cover my life you you don't do
this you want to be James O'Keefe
undercover journalist but then when it
happens to you it's like clutching at
your at your pearls which you probably
have in your costume Department Crowder
let's be honest and like you said it
wasn't like you said I want privacy in
this matter he came out with a video the
tone of the first video was look you
don't know this [__] that was the tone
of that video okay where you went
um what like most people would just like
you said go hey look guys it's not a
great time right now you know my
family's going through it we got kids
like you said it's my mother my kids
we're kind of rolling around on the mud
a little bit in court right now but I
don't want any ill will towards her and
I don't want to talk about it on the air
but he came out with this whole like
look you don't know what what hurtful oh
my side of it she's a [__] and you're
like why are you freaking out dude yeah
can you imagine like you know the
internet's forever and we you know back
in back I don't know how old you guys
are but like back in my day like this
stuff wasn't kept forever right like we
did is before the end yeah all my
MySpace [__] is gone bro
yeah all that's gone and so you know
these kids are going to grow up and
they're going to find this video of
their dad talking [__] about their moms
that's not going to make them feel too
good provided that they still even have
a relationship with him at this point uh
depending on his attitude so I don't
know you just I would hate to see that I
would hate to see you know my parents
like talking [__] about each other
online and inviting media coverage and
Dad talking about releasing mom's
medical records and calling potentially
allegedly calling her crazy or hinting
that she's got medical problems or
mental problems it's just it's not a
good look um I don't know you'd think
his lawyers he's got so many that one of
them would be like hey man like grab a
drink let's talk this out let's let's
like ask for privacy let's lay low and
just forget about it and I don't know I
don't know what they were thinking I
don't know why you know none of
Crowder's people he's checked him he's
like his ego there he's got like Saul
Goodman lawyers they're like listen I'll
plant drugs in her car just to the
courthouse I'm gonna look I got a guy he
gets in the trunk nice and clean all
right go for it your honor I have it on
very good authority she's got meth in
her car right now oh they go out there
to pound a meth oh but no Tony this has
been uh uh
thanks for coming on we really do
appreciate it current revolt on Twitter
uh currentvault.com what else uh would
you like people to find you or or come
get at you I've been posted in the
article in the uh in the chat room as
well which I think yeah I appreciate
that if you guys are listening and
you're you're lean right or right
Wingers um subscribe to us if you don't
live in Texas you're gonna think we're
boring as hell so don't bother reading
us uh don't bother subscribing because
you're just gonna get Texas news in your
in your inbox every morning but if
you're leaving Texas and you want right
wing news uh subscribe to us at
careerbuild.com but nice meeting you all
appreciate you guys thank you so much
for coming on man yeah 3 700 watch it on
Rumble I'm sure we got a couple yeah we
got some new people yeah we're good and
by and next next time you're in court
you want to come on you're more than
welcome to come on man yeah we plan on
covering it um provided that they don't
try harder to cover the court date so we
should be able to find it um and when we
do we'll uh let you all know and we go
out your way every once in a while too
man so good when we're out there we'll
uh we'll link up and uh
steak yeah yeah man hey thanks so much
Tony we really appreciate it thank you
man nice to meet you thank you thank you
buddy see you later
goes yeah that was great man that was
great hearing what was happening in
there that was that was that was
wonderful uh thank you there's a bunch
of people running around Rumble right
now going [__] well I mean we're on the
front page no I know I'm not saying like
in trouble trouble but I'm just saying I
think there's a couple little emails
going around
[Laughter]
I don't know what the [__] are they
doing
what we're doing is showing how amazing
Rumble is it doesn't matter diversity
and opinion it's diversity of opinion
Free Speech here that's what Rumble
believes in and that's what we believe
here at revenge of this uh man that was
that was great again go check out his
Twitter uh thank you to everybody yeah
we'll figure out about those quartz
transcripts let's figure that out